hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the tank allele a series and
there are three reasons why I decided to
show this game one because so many of
you have requested that - it's the only
game tank one in this match and three it
could very well be the last game any a
human ever won against Leela as they
said if tank manages to win one game
against Leela she will get an upgrade
and after that who knows if she will
ever ever be able to be beaten by humans
so let's just take a look at this so
it's a hyper bullet game it's a game
played after the match it's so we could
say an exhibition game and before the
game
penguins the rating unleashes this 2920
912 in ultra bullet and Leela's rating
is thirty two hundred and thirty three
so Allah is much higher rated than
penguin and it might be weird to you why
are you showing us an ultra bullet game
first and first a bullet game you know
and then an ultra bullet game well
because this game doesn't really have
any mistakes it's it's I mean the game
wasn't it was played precisely and it
contains a lot less mistakes than a lot
of a lot of games I show you in
classical time format so other than
leave us crazy blunder this game is
perfectly fine so let's see it in this
game andrew also has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 we have Knight to
f6 c4 e6 and Knight to c3 the five
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined
we have seek after Sundy 5e captors on
d5 the exchange variation and now Bishop
to g5 Bishop to e7 e 3 we have castles
by Lila Han Bishop the T to the earth to
d3 and this is so far all standard
Theory c5 d captures and c5 Bishop
captures on c5 and night the g2e to
Lilla brings back the Bishop to e7 so
the knight can now move we have castles
and Knight to c6 rook to c1 simply
developing h6 Bishop to f4 and now a a6
not allowing night to b5
we have h3 making room for
a bishop on h2 and now comes the Bishop
to e6 Bishop does come to h2 and here we
see the start of Lila's great plan here
Lila plays d4 we have Knight captures on
d4 I mean this pawn is a free pawn
Knight captures pawn captures and this
is the magical moment where it all
happens
in this position well of course you can
to grab the phone back but it seems that
this is something alia has a problem
with as there was there was even another
game where Lila made the same mistake
although she won the game because Andrew
simply didn't have enough time to play
it out but here Olivia played Queen
captures on d4 so let's see it once
again Lila is currently rated thirty two
hundred and thirty three in an ultra
bullet and she plays Queen captures on
d4 so if you're new to this match if
you're new to these games feel free to
pause the video and find the best move
for white here so I'm sure you won't
need more than a couple of seconds if
you found that congratulations you've
just defeated an artificial intelligence
with neural network rated 30 and 200 the
[ __ ] the move is Bishop to h7 check now
whatever black plays Lila played King
captures on h7 and now it seemed to play
Queen captures on d4 and it's a free
queen and Andrew was really if he didn't
really believe he just won a queen
against Lila he was still kind of
waiting to see what he missed but he was
simply continued playing rook a to the
8th Queen to e3 and now rook F to e8 so
you know developing rooks preparing to
move them on an open or an open lines
she's down a queen but she continues
playing this game nice to e4
we have Bishop captures an a2 Knight
captures on f6 would check Bishop
captures and Queen to f3 Bishop captures
and b2 grabbing another pawn what's the
idea that after tank plays rook to c2
which he does Bishop to d5 now with an
attack on the Queen so the tank doesn't
win a piece here now comes Queen to d3
this comes with check
comes to e34 now Queen to b3 and now
Bishop captures uncie - so even grabbing
a rock a queen captures Bishop with
check King moves and Queen captures the
other Bishop and now it's a queen rook
and the bishop against two rooks so a
completely winning position for tank but
it's ultra bullet he has only a few
seconds on the clock and you know you
have to play this like only the most
precise moves will win you this games at
this game with a couple of seconds on
the clock b5 by Leela Bishop to e5 going
for the g7 pawned f6 and Bishop captures
on f6 so given up the bishop just to
open up the King and try and take
advantage of the weak position of the
King captures captures and now rook to
f8 we have Queen to g6 check King to h8
and now not bothering with Queen
captures on h6 here and you can grab an
easy draw against Leela but even with
two seconds on the clock he still wants
to win the game rook e1 we have rook to
be seven and now rook to e6 rook to g7
attacking the Queen Queen captures King
to g8 and now rook to g6 rook captures
and Queen captures with check so here I
believe you can check it in there is a
link in the description below where you
can see all the games from the entire
match here and you had only one second
on the clock and still he doesn't want
to draw he still wants to win so King
here we have Queen captures on a6 and
these are all pre moves so what happened
next Queen b6 going for the pawn Queen
captures Leela doesn't really have
anything to do here he if she's trying
to flag Andrew Queen to g3 rook to g7
and here you can see that oh yeah I mean
if if if a human had this position
against another human who had a second
on the clock you would never give up
your rook here
you would of course try to make white
white lose some time but at least a
little is fair in this regard so rogue
g7 Queen character scheme captures and
now Andrew starts rushing those pawns
upwards and he says he has less than a
second I believe it's 0.9 seconds but
you know every move is a pre move but
still he has no problems in maneuvering
this game so you just have to be careful
as you are pre moving all the
not nuts the stalemate the black King
about here comes g7 and there is no
problem here
we have Queen g6 check and here comes
another queen to the board and now it's
the checkmate that we all know and love
since the time we first played chess
queen - h1 a beautiful checkmate and
here you have it this is the only game
Andrew won against Leela and like I said
this could very well be the last game
anyone ever won against Leela so yeah
you did you did ask for it there it is I
do hope you enjoyed it that's the last
I'll be showing from the Andrew tank vs.
leave a series and yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it
tomorrow we're gonna check up on chunky
chunky Chess Championship and also at
the United States Championship thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
with another interesting video hopefully
thank you all